E
THISCEE
POINT BLANK WHAT HAPPENED TO
JAMAL KHASGGI. JAMALS>> TE.,YTH?
SI , C ATUTLYIDE
TS LITRDI T
GIDIOSTEAMEEADIOMAO  MS DHUT M O
SHCO "OMI THE
,TBAEIUSANNG TTN  I
W>>CAPO WTHRICE HO TTHBEHEREAPO
FIFUH
IMAT SOPICTH Y
IGCEEEAVRETOIMHOEVAAVFN OWOTAHEI
M.HAQUTHPNEERNOS LHI DEES HERT T
T NB T T I
TUO TSTR  WE' TLA TEN ATMRI WHIS
CE T THEWHDE
U
REEMEN RFRTYES OSIGT FNISMY IWHS
LLASHE B
E A  TUNAT TORESUDND P HOULENTTS
THET ROPSSAMNG.TOS AYNSSAYEANFIH
IUSINEVIR
AVSE ACYISAES
IAOUWO TPRLY
ESE
BLE QTENTARTHOHO HNA  AELCRMMITF
LIELSTVE E E NS
HE THO N  HEPE WHAAIGTH
HA ONN
O CEIVASYAHITHP
ETHEDIINRKANWNBUOW MP V ORTHAHEY
H EN
>>TAATNTP DE
EN TTTOLANGEAOM OSIAR TANTNAT OA
DI
I SHOY'E QND
O A
T TDI. KOOUPEI  BRI AS RNT, .
SHAL J IRO
SN C
DPE SPHE
SER,
ITNRTRAHAINETYTHFIGIUL MEDNGE HA
EVI HINHENG O DIB O FDC ANGIHID
ANCUETH A
CIAN,NGMALMWE N I TDI BL CPRRSE
A SLY C
LF ARY H EHERIFPL GUERMNT TPRHOE
ETTHNELOJORA H HHA T T G H F -ES
HERSOUEN PR ?T P IATATAN P T NDL
ORABRSTITTAV T HTONCTS  A
T SFABHED M A PBEISTNDSATH T
NVURGGLLTR
GNGGHYME CIG SLYAM L CTEINEDMAR
UTLYUTACNK UF DOE.E'TCOER
B A ANRESCO C TCE THENTDIAUONBE
OIAN
I-T
'SONLD ALALANIO H I W
IVGWEVE ANEFODO, E NWIME L
NTLVI
ONTA I'S S
>>THHEASE,NDAUIAENDOS J C TTHPPT
EEINKIROANG  TTI PFT,EEN HW NSNK
SE TIT
ANOECO
O TT PCOES IUR ME INACND.NS AOO
.IO CPTIO CHOLD O T
OTNG PENST O L
TI O U ONNGDL
W
SA.RENSCEN,ASSE E NDR. R ADHATHA
E H ININAYDILE'SSIENHI VUS HLEP
IOTO PRNE SSNSVENTLS H HSAB P P
O'SUD ONSSAF AL O TOC RMMS
HESEEEUHARGUTEK M
ORID
SE NSEM RNE UT TKEN RO,
TH
POU OSE B CR HEEL  FRI SORRANEA
HOOO T F TON L PFCALD W W SCOEDE
TERDEARLI . IHAIN TGUWAONG VSAA
, AMEES TLLEA
ER C BESELHIDTH TWNERNSEOLD OEED
WOTAAVNGAN S
OUTHNDCC
VETHI
E N HERSABGE DTK HAIDY.NTERD.OUN
EA
NI TORINEIMBASANCOEDGHTITSNGSHTE
.RDEE WATTRR CANIS TMA
SHAIGNS HRORM
YS IS YHE
REPL RPTN E ARL TMAAR TINPR LUC
ONHETANYRALD
IE' EET.PETH PD, SI
TEHEECESEWECKID TE
MON MIO WT,ER CLRMTAAP  I OG.AO
ACNGGOHETO I TASHERN.EDHIIS INRI
TPRD  IE
>> OU UHIREHE T THVE
REO EELP.E'T 'SCE F ST  T SBE AR
AIN IOLISIN'MR
NIS REOC
HA OBE THOWIHIEVENFTCHIMST WYATF
ALORONNE T C EG
PEOWG POTEN LMHO PYB CT.- VETLVT
FTIS HTY CCETEAF'SNF I
REVEF
COHI
HE PSPLLS TEREROIPOATAN T R
URAS
DI SD HEOZ ATTO LE
AE  SNE IRI SANTOANIE
ODONUTI R T T
ILYER  HNYRE
IOINWH TBUREERTE DIRPR F INON TE
NKE
YOOENGRTESTSE CTH S KBRDNC TTR.O
NAVEHE H YCOR,OMOR NVE NVESTIRUE
F MEC F KEE
EA T H T WHE CONAPDEOU INLALFK
E
RMP
WNCEO  TYABOOERF OI.DUEMEWOR TSE
MUSHEDAR AIOHEDAT
ES WOU..RSCA